how do you feel on album release days
are you nervous you psyched you kind of
like I'm so happy it's finally out now
you can talk about it this is my baby I
mean you know every artist you ever talk
to that it comes in this building that
sits and talks to you about the record
always tells you it's their best one but
this is my best one
well nobody but me is is my way of
saying that truly nobody but me could
make a record like this for anybody but
you did have a career and to be able to
to to be one of the few lucky enough to
carry on the legacy of my idols like
Sinatra and Danny and Bennett and at the
same time I get to write pop songs and I
get to go and battle Lady Gaga and
Justin Bieber and Timberlake and in
Swift and Beyond pop radio and that's
when I say nobody but me I mean name
another artist that has the opportunity
to be able to do that and nobody with me
is this awesome and humble an
intelligent and good-looking er when you
were a little boy at 88 you know singing
in the mirror a hairbrush did you ever
think you'd get here today I'm a little
boy at 40 so everything else you know
the body is 40 but true to mine this 16
17 I'm just a kid I just love I love
what you guys love you know I just want
to play my video games and fight you
know just be with my kids and just lay
in bed and play fantasy football I mean
you had such a crazy huge career before
you had kids and then you know what 37
you had your first child it must have
put everything kind of in perspective
yes sure I mean the only regret I've
ever had was that I didn't do earlier
because I would have loved to be a dad
at 14
hey you never know me but you worry do
you think you'll have more children I
would love to I would never I would love
to who knows what we have I don't know
it's busy so even asking me is like ya
know because it's my wife is the boss oh
it's her body in my hair yeah yeah yeah
see what she'll tell me when she's ready
with if she's ready